hello I'm Brett Leiter the design lead
for Android wear and welcome to the
Android wear to dot o developer preview
tour let's talk about Android wear to
dot o so as always
Android wear starts you out on the watch
face here I've got a watch face that's
very one dot oh it's beautiful
but it doesn't have a lot of information
and action on it to help me with my day
so I'm gonna swipe from left to right on
the watch face and what that does is
zooms out on the watch face and actually
helps me select my next watch base
elements analog elements analog is a
watch base that we built to demonstrate
the capabilities of the complications
API
I've already customized it with a set of
things that help me so let's dig into
this maybe I want to change one of these
complications from calories to tracking
how much water I've had to drink so I
just swipe left right to zoom out a bit
i tap on the gear icon i tap on the
complications the left one and we've
worked with a life some a third party
partner to have them be a data provider
for these two things so I'm gonna switch
over to water as the complication and
boom I've just changed from calories to
tracking how many glasses of water and
it looks like I'm a little behind on my
water today but I can is just as easily
launched Strava check out what's going
on in my calendar or see what time it is
in London and each of these
complications is interactive in that I
can tap to get more details and launch
into that app okay let's keep going
let's go over to this next watch face
Ranger by zoo honden and here Ranger
which has a completely different
aesthetic but its styling its
complications to match that aesthetic
yeah it's using the data providers so
it's got the time zone in Boston where
my family lives it's also got the water
tracker and it's got the day of the
month so we really think that watch
bases should own the presentation of
their complications to make those
complications fit in so nicely with the
watch face okay so I've got Ranger here
let's see if what else I might be
interested in for a watch base so at the
end of the watch base favorites I've got
a
first of all the watch faces that are
available on the device and I'll pick
elements Digital here and now I've added
that to my favorites so I've got four
mmm you know I don't need this one auto
style watch face anymore so I'm gonna
get rid of it
so I'll have to do is just swipe it up
and it's gone and now elements analog is
my watch face so now that we've shown
how to select and discard watch faces
let's go check out another core
capability of Android wear which is how
you get back so here I might be deep in
my list of possible watch faces and I
decide you know none of these quite
resonate with me so I want to go back so
all I have to do is hit the hardware
button here once to go back to the list
of favorites and then once more to go
back to my default watch face so hitting
the hardware button on the side of the
device is just how you get back and it's
super fast so up next let's take a look
at what we call the quick settings shade
so all I have to do is pull down from
the top edge of the watch face and I've
got all the controls that I might need
to access in a hurry especially I want
to focus on brightness so we've heard
from users that brightness needed to be
easier to access and so here's that's
well that's what we've done so all you
have to do is tap up and down and you
get a live preview of the brightness
right on top of your watch face
so now I'll hit the back button on the
side of the watch once and then a second
time and I'm back on the watch face okay
now that we've seen watch bases and
quick settings let's check out apps so
once I'm on the watch face and the
screen is is fully on all I have to do
is hit the hardware button on the side
of the watch and boom that launches the
app launcher let's try that again so I'm
on the watch face and I just hit the
hardware button on the side and I'm into
the app launcher and so the app launcher
as you can tell has this brown specific
way out for round watches and it's also
gonna scroll bar on the side so I can
really quickly and easily maybe even
fling down to the app that I want and
once when I found that app like Strava I
get zoomed into it and so I can interact
with Strava here you know go on a bike
ride and then when I'm done I hit the
hardware button and I go back out to the
to the app launcher right where I was
before and if I leave the app launcher
hit the hardware button to go back to
the watch face
and of course if I hit the hardware
button again to go back into the app
launcher here's Strava right at the top
of the app launcher so the apps that I
use the most are really easy to get to
in the app launcher
okay so let's go back out to the watch
face and now let's check out messaging
so messaging is something we've spent a
lot of time focusing on with Android
wear - dotto to make it really really
good so if my watch was in always-on
mode and I received a notification from
a friend that notification comes up over
my watch face always-on mode and shows
for a few seconds before it goes away
then when I wake my watch back up that
notification will come and visit my
watch base for a few seconds and then go
away so it doesn't cover up my watch
face but I can see that I've got a
notification so when I'm ready I can
scroll up and start interacting with
that notification so here Cristal's sent
me a notification during my demo awesome
so yeah I'll reply to crystal here and I
think I'll end up using the keyboard
because I want to be pretty expressive
and specific but you know I'm already
talking so I can't really speak my reply
so I'm using my suggestions here which I
would say are indeed pretty good and the
demo seems to be going pretty good so
far as well so I just approve that and
reply and I can see that my message has
been appended to our conversation and my
conversations been been persisted and
crystals already applied awesome well
I'm done with this conversation with
crystal for now so I'll hit the back
button and I'll be taken back to the
stream and I can scroll down I save got
a message from Alexandra and I've got
some activity from Google fit and as you
can see it as I'm scrolling I can see a
scroll bar in thumbnail that lets me
know exactly where I am in the stream
and approximately how many notifications
I have to deal with okay
so I'll hit the hardware button and go
back up to the top at my watch face and
that concludes our tour thanks everyone
let us know what you think about the
Developer Preview of Android wear -
dotto